here now is candace allen founder of
lexit host of the canis owen show
candace
what your reaction to this i think i i
thought i had seen it all candace but i
hadn't
absolutely have not seen it all and
there will be more to come i can promise
you that laura listen the biden
administration got caught red-handed and
i want to be very clear about what their
intentions are because we all know that
joseph biden does not care about race
his
record when he was a senator tells us
everything that we need to know about
him and his opinion about black people
and it's true being a black american is
that we are the dumbest part of the
population he believes that black
americans are the easy pawns
administration believes
that if they keep stroking racial
tensions they can turn black americans
into permanent soldiers for their
policies and what they're really trying
to do is replace hard academics i'm
talking about
engineering mathematics all that stuff
is now a form of white supremacy they
don't want kids to get the right answer
they want them to focus on
you said it laura emotional learning
right because emotional learning is not
rational learning people that learn
emotionally don't tend to go off and
become successful individuals rather
people that learn emotionally turn to
become angry
radical antifa throwing blm burning
individuals
and those people are are very easily
targeted by the government that's what
the biden regime wants
they really want people to do whatever
they say to be angry pawns for their
government schemes
well candace i can't tell you how many
diversity
equity and inclusion positions if you
just do a random
search online which i did today
so many companies are looking for dei
officers it's the biggest scam going
you have instant job security and you
can never get fired i guess unless you
actually
treat people just as equals without
regard to race then you'll probably be
fine
right right that's exactly right and by
the way that's antithetical to free
markets and capitalism eventually that
will die out because you can't just hire
people because of the way that they look
i mean
another company will come around they'll
hire people because of what they know
and your company will lose against them
it's a ridiculous policy that people are
doing
to really capitulate with you know the
black lives matter radical movement
that went after all these businesses i
think that will stop but i don't think
um this watering down of the education
system is going to stop actually i think
we're just seeing the beginning of it
and and it's unfortunate people need to
realize that right now in american
society and this is a fact
i read it in a thomas soul book we've
never handed out more degrees ever in
american society and yet we've never
produced kids that are this dumb and i
mean this by statistic i'm talking about
by standardized test scores these kids
are not becoming smarter and yet they're
getting more and more degrees and that's
by design
they want these kids to be convinced of
their own rationality be convinced that
they're so smart
and then be shocked when they can't make
any money because you actually can't
make that money as a gender studies or
an lgbt studies major
for four years that's not just not what
society needs i need somebody to fix my
ac
not to come over and tell me uh that
there's more there's 26 000 genders and
you can be non-binary so these kids end
up angry they think they're mad at
capitalism they think they're mad at
free markets what they should be mad at
are democrats well candace have you
really not
seen how much abram candy makes per
appearance
i think he does like a 20 minute zoom
and gets 20 dollars so
some of them do make a lot of money on
the uh dei stuff for the blm stuff but
uh that's a point well said candace your
point is keep them dumb in school with
crt
maybe keep them numb on pot dumb on you
know that's that we got it all set now
it's all going to work out perfectly
great to see you tonight
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else